- Makes your breath bacon-fresh.
I can only imagine how putrid my breath
must smell right now.
(upbeat music)
- I was raised kosher
and then I became a
vegetarian for a lot of years,
so I've actually had very
little bacon-eating time
in my life.
- I remember what it tastes like.
It was good.
It smells good, tastes good,
just not a fan of eating pigs.
- I mean I do miss bacon.
Who the hell doesn't miss bacon?
- I sometimes miss the taste of bacon
but now they have fake bacon stuff,
so who cares!
- So I guess these are crackers
that have been imbued
with the spirit of bacon.
- Smells like really fatty, fatty bacon.
- This really isn't made with any...
It's just like this, interesting.
- The bacon is subtle.
- I feel like it smells more bacon-y
than it tastes, but it's good.
- I imagine the person that wants this
is also the person that
like gets mad at me
for not eating meat even
if I didn't bring it up.
- It has little fake bacon chunks
(chuckles) in the chocolate.
- Bacon bits. Vegetarian.
I've had plenty of those.
- There's even a little fake fat in there.
- It's crunchy.
- If someone gave this
to me I wouldn't even
like pinpoint the bacon flavor at all.
- They're the color of bacon. Ugh.
Whoa. Tastes like feet.
- It's like a mix of mint
and smoky bacon flavor.
- I'm getting it, it's smoky.
- Impossible to blow a bubble with this.
- (blowing) No.
- (blowing) Kinda.
- (snap) I just blew a snot bubble
at the same time I blew this bubble.
- It looks like normal toothpaste.
Like there's no red stripe which is nice.
- Circles that's what
you're supposed to do.
- Put it on my tongue.
- This doesn't taste like bacon.
It just tastes like mint mixed with
some sort of like weird smoky flavor.
- This is just dog things
repurposed as human things.
Maybe this is why my dog
doesn't like getting her teeth brushed.
- There's an after taste of bacon.
A little bit.
- I feel like it would
be smart for a dentist
to approve it if it does prevent cavities.
Let's say you have a little kid
who won't brush their
teeth but loves bacon...
You can get them bacon toothpaste.
- I hope my dentist is watching this.
- Ooh okay. If you're gonna have breath
of any sort and it's not minty.
Bacon's not a horrible option.
- I think this could fool someone
into thinking this is
what bacon tastes like
if they haven't eaten it
in longer than I have.
- I think I've realized through today
none of these products have made me
either yearn for more bacon in my life,
nor more bacon flavor in my life.
- If I was at all missing meat
before this experience I am so happy
with just cutting it out.
(upbeat music)